ونحييكم الى تفاصيل الملف الاول جهود
الوساطه في اليمن التي تقودها دول التحالف
العربي ودول مجلس التعاون الخليجي بقياده
السعوديه نحو ايجاد عمليه سياسيه شامله
لاستعاده مؤسسه الدوله تشير المعطيات الى
تقدم فيها وفي مؤشر على تحقيق تقدم غير
مسبوق في مسارحه للازمه تحدثت وسائل
الاعلام المواجهه للحوثيين عن ان رؤيه
السعوديه للحل وفقا للتفاهمات مع صنعاء ما
زالت قيد التداول والنقاش لكنها شبه
نهائيه وقالت ان الرؤيه السعوديه تقوم على
البحث خلال المرحله الانتقاليه في مستقبل
شكل الدوله والحكومه التي ستحكم السلاح
وتلقت الشرق الاوسط عن مصدر يمني ان مسوده
سلام شامله للازمه يتم وضع اللمسات
الاخيره لها برعايه امميه واضافت الصحيفه
ان جميع الملفات طرحت خلال النقاشات بما
فيها القضيه الجنوبيه فيما ذكرت رويترز ان
المحادثات في صنعاء تركز على اعاده الفتح
الكامل للموانئ التي يسيطر عليها الحوثيون
بالاضافه الى مطار صنعاء ودفع رواتب
موظفها الحكومه من عائده النفط بالاضافه
الى توسيع القائمه كتمهيد يسبق استكمال
الاجراءات السياسيه الاخرى التي ستناقش
لاحقا او ستناقش ترتيبات اداره وشكل
الدوله
بنود محادثات الحوثيين والوفدين السعودي
والعماني تمديد الهدنه التي توسطت فيها
الامم المتحده والمنتهيه في اكتوبر الماضي
اعاده فتح الموانئ
فتح مطار صنعاء بالكامل
اضافه لدفع رواتب الموظفين الحكوميين
وبحث جهود اعاده بناء اليمن
صحيفه الشرق الاوسط قالت ان من بين البنود
التفاوض المباشر لتاسيس شكل الدوله وصولا
الى المرحله الانتقاليه اخيرا
مساء الخير
المشاهدين وضيوفك الكرام اعتقد ان مساله
المسوده هي مسوده
[موسيقى]
اعتقد اذا اردت ان اصفها فهي متخمه كثيرا
بالتفاصيل نحن لا ندعينا طلعنا على كافه
التفاصيل ولكن نشرنا ما استطعنا ان نؤكده
سابقا من ابرز المراحل التي ستشمل هذه
المسوده ولا ننسى انها ما زالت قيد
الدراسه والمراجعه
لما تتحدث عن تفاصيل اضافيه لا نتحدث فقط
على وقف دائم لاطلاق النار نتحدث
عنه ممكن ان تنسحب على مشوار او مسار
سياسي
بكل تاكيد وقف اطلاق النار هو في الاساس
[موسيقى]
هو العمليه الرئيسيه لانطلاق اي مفاوضات
اخرى او اجراءات انسانيه او اقتصاديه وما
الى ذلك طبعا هذه المسوده كما قلنا هي
ليست
محسومه بعد ولكنها ترسم الخريطه التي من
الممكن ان
نترقب اعلانها قريبا وهي بالاجراءات
والمراحل والتفصيلات التي على اثرها ستكون
بدايه النهايه لن نستطيع ان نقول ان الحرب
ذات الاعوام التسعه سوف تنتهي وان اليمن
سيعود غدا في سلم ويكون هناك انتخابات نحن
نتمنى ذلك ولكن المنطق والواقع يقول ان
هذه العمليه سوف تستغرق الكثير من المراحل
الكثير من الاشهر والكثير من السنوات هي
الحرب دمت تسعه وثمانيه سنوات يبدو بان
هناك اضافه لسنه اضافيه على كل لا اعلم
سيد بدر كيف حسبتها
الحرب بدات انقلاب الحوثيين في سبتمبر
2014 على الدوله وما اعقبها من ذلك عاصفه
الحزم كانت رده فعل وليست فعلا فاذا اردنا
ان نحسب فهي تقريبا ثمانيه اعوام ويعلم
مشارف العام التاسع وفي الاخير لا يريد
اليمنيون اعتقد مزيدا من السنوات لا يكون
رقمين لكي يكونوا عشره اعوام نتمنى ان
نتوقف عند الثمانيه حتى ولا نصل الى
التاسع صحيح هذا ما يتمناه الكل في الواقع
ويبدو بان هناك
نيه للبدء بتشكيل
مسار معين لتهدئه مستمره ولكن دكتور علي
يبقى السؤال كيف هل من رؤيه مشتركه يمكن
ان نتحدث عنها بين طرفين نتحدث عن طرف
الشرعيه الذي يبني موقفه على مبادئ
دستوريه على مبادرات دوليه على قرارات
امميه على مبادرات خليجيه ونتحدث عن طرف
في المقابل وهو
الحوثي الذي سيطر على الحكم بقوه السلاح
مهما تكون تفاصيل الماضي في المستقبل هل
يمكن البناء على رؤيه مشتركه حقيقيه
اولا مساء الخير وتحيه لك
والضيوفك الكرام
وللمشاهدين الاعزاء
الواقع ان يعني
هذا الوضع الذي نحن الان
نمر فيه هو تشكل يعني في ضوء الرفض الحوثي
[موسيقى]
المرجعيات يعني في البدايه هم وقعوا على
مخرجات الحوار الوطني وهي مرجعيه مهمه
وقعوا على المخرجات ثم ثم تراجعوا بعد ذلك
وعملوا الانقلاب واستولوا على العاصمه
بقوه السلاح
وعندما صدرت قرارات مجلس الامن وبده القرن
22 سته عشر الحسين اخذوا موقف رافض
لهذا القرار على اعتبار انهم كانوا في
الحكم
وان القرار يلزمهم باعاده
المؤسسه التي سيطروا عليها ولهذا دكتور
علي طرحت سؤال يتعلق بالمستقبل لان
التفاصيل الماضي تعلم حضرتك بانها عديده
والخلافات بين الطرفين الرؤيه المشتركه
يمكن ان تكون قائمه بين طرفين قد تكون هل
هو عميقه بينهما خاصه مع سنوات الاقتتال
بينهما
فعلا يعني الامر هنا يتوقف على مدى
استعداد الحوثيين لان يغيروا من مواقفهم
ازاء المرجعيات لانه في تقديرنا لا يمكن
ان يكون هناك حل الا بالاستند الى هذه
المرجعيات هي الاساس الذي يمكن على اساسه
استعاده الدوله
وتحقيق
التعايش بين الاطراف المختلفه
البحث عن مرجعيات جديده هذا طبعا ستكون
عمليه طويله وعمليه لا اعتقد انها ستحظى
بموافقه من كافه الاطراف يعني اذا اراد
الحسين ان يفرضوا مرجعياتهم فانا اعتقد
انه لن يوافقهم احد على هذه المرجعيات
عليهم فعلا ان يعودوا مره اخرى وان
يلتزموا بما قد سبق وافقوا عليه وان
يلحنوا امام اراده المجتمع الدولي وان
يقبلوا بقرار مجلس الامن الذي ممكن ان
يحدث فيه بعض التعديلات التي تستوعب
المتطوره
التي حدثت اما بالنسبه
دكتورنا جميل تتحدث على وجوب ان ينحني
الحوثيون ولكن لا تستثني بان يجب ان تكون
هناك تعديلات سالتقد التعديلات سنحاول ان
نكون
بقدر ما ايجابي لمحاوله فهم هذه التطورات
استاذ محمد هل يجب على الحوث فقط ان يلتزم
بمخرجات الحوارات السابقه والمبادرات او
كذلك على الطرف المقابل ان يتعامل بشيء من
اللين
اهلا وسهلا مساء الخير وعليك وعلى جميع
المشاهدين والمستمعين الاكارم وعلى جميع
الضيوف
اليوم الشرعيه الدستوريه امثله بمجلس
القياده الرئاسي
وكذلك التحالف العربي لديهم النيه الصادقه
والجاده منذ اول يوم بل ان المجلس الرئاسي
بعد تاسيس كان اول خطاب لفخامه الرئيس
الدكتور رشاد العليمي ان نحن مجلس من اجل
السلام من اجل بناء اليمن من اجل اللحم
الوطنيه من اجل حقن الدماء وكان صادق في
جميع كلماته كان صادق ايضا في جميع
المواقف جميع التحركات الدوليه طالب
المجتمع الدولي طالبا الهيئات الدوليه
المهتمه بشان اليمني ان نحن وكذلك التحالف
العربي يمد ايدينا للسلام في اليمن ولكن
حتى في الجهه المقابله كل تصريحات الحوثي
تقول بان الهدف واحد وهو احقاق السلام
المشكله في المسار المشكله في الاليه
المشكله في
مختلفه بين الطرفين تحقيق هذا السلام
الحوثيون لم يكونوا جادين في في التزامهم
بالمواثيق في التزامهم بالمعاهدات الدوليه
في التزامهم ايضا بالهدره الانسانيه التي
ترعاها الامم المتحده بينما نحن كنا في
هدنه كانت الميليشيات الحوثيه يوميا تصوب
قذائفها وصواريخها وكاتوشياتها
والقذائف والقذائف الهون والمدفعيه
والدبابات على الاهالي وعلى منازل
المواطنين وعلى الاهل يعني الاحياء
المكتظه بالساكنين لم تتوقف يوما عن
تحشيدها لم تتوقف المليشيات الحوثيه بيوما
من الايام خلال الهدنه التي رعتها الامم
المتحده خلال الفتره الماضيه عن فتح
المعسكرات عن تجنيد الاطفال عن زج عن
تعبئه الجبهات عن
تحريك بعض الكتائب من محافظات الى محافظات
اخرى بل ان الميليشيات الحوثيات دائما
تعودنا منها ان كل هدنه انسانيه
تستغلها الميليشيات في تحشيدها تعبئه
جبهاتها
وحل بعض مشاكل الضعف الذي يكون لديها في
بعض الجبهات نحن في الشرعيه وكذلك التحالف
كنا ملتزمين بل ان يعني
ان نحن كنا نطالب الامم المتحده مرارا
وتكرارا ان الميليشيات الحوثيه تكثف من
قصفى في بعض المحافظات تكثف من قصفه في
التعشيده في بعض الجبهه
حتى صحيح ولكن حتى في المقابل وانقل دون
تبني حتى في المقابل كذلك تصريحات الحوثي
تضع خطوط حمراء على بعض
الترتيبات هي تقول بان موقفي واضح وبانه
يجب اولا تحرير كما تقول هي تستخدم هذا
المصطلح الموانئ مطر صنعاء الرواتب هي
كذلك تطرح مجموعه من النقاط وتقول بان
الشرعيه لا تلتزم بتحقيق هذه النقاط بكل
هذا هناك ازمه ثقه انقلها للاستاذ سالم
استاذ سالم الجانب العماني لطالما كان
الوسيط المتابع لكل مسار المحادثات هل
تعتقد بانه هذه المرحله في هذه الفتره
هناك فعلا محاوله لتذليل هذه العوائق
ولمحاوله تقريب هذه الجهات وسيبنى على ايه
مبادئ
شكرا لك اولا واسعد الله اوقاتكم
وتحيه لايضا ضيوفكم وكذلك مشاهديكم اينما
كانوا
الجهود العمانيه استطاعت خلال الشهور
الماضيه يبدو منذ اكثر من عام ان تبني جزء
من هذه الثقه بين الاطراف في الازمه
اليمنيه بما فيها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وايضا استطاعت ان تفتح قنوات
ومسارات اخرى تساهم في حلحله الازمه من
خلال ايضا
التوافق السعودي الايراني في الاسابيع
الماضيه هذه كلها في النهايه ساهمت على
ايجاد ارضيه وان كانت ارضيه لا تكفي بشكل
يساهم في تسريع الحلف اليمني لكن القناعات
الان التقت في هذه المساحه وانا على ثقه
بان جميع الاطراف في الازمه اليمنيه في
الداخل هي الان يعني مقتنعه تماما بان
الحلول العسكريه مستحيله سواء كانت من
الطرف الشمالي او من الطرف الجنوبي سلطنه
عمان استطاعت ايضا ان تغير من بعض
المعادلات في جهودها حقيقه المغنيه
والمستمره التي ايضا تمكنت فيها من
المعادلات المتعلقه بماذا بايه ملفات مثلا
كان هناك تعديل او تغيير فيها بما يرضي
الطرفين
من ضمن الخطوات والمعادلات ان هناك بني
حوارا بهذه الجهود التي نتحدث عنها
وتقودها مسقط بين الرياض وبين صنعاء عام
وهذا الوفد الثاني الذي الان يزور صنعاء
كما تعلمون وهذا مهم جدا ايضا هناك
تطور في الموقف في موقف انصار الله في
صنعاء
باهميه العلاقه ووجوب ايضا الحلول مع
الطرف ايضا السعودي ثم هناك ايضا المسار
الذي دفعت في سلطنه عمان بين الرياض
وطهران خلال الفتره الماضيه وبجهود العراق
وكذلك بجهود الصين هذه كلها في النهايه
شكلت ايضا جانبا ضاغطا في ضروره التقاء
الاطراف جميعا الحل اليوم يتمثل في تلبيه
نسبه عاليه جدا من المطالب
المطالب انصار الله باستثناء دفع رواتب
العسكريين كل هذه المطاعم المطار والمواني
وكذلك رفع الحصار عن بعض المناطق اضافه
الى موضوع تدفق الاموال الى الموظفين في
الشمال بالتساوي مع الجنوب توحيد البنك
المركزي خطوات سوف تاتي يعني يعني تباعا
الان
ليس لديهم اي سبب ما تطرحه حضرتك مهم
للغايه ستاتي اتباعا بمعنى انه تم التوافق
عليها باستثناء دفع مرتبات العسكريين يعني
الاتفاق تم ينتظر
نشره فقط
النقاط الاساسيه في الاتفاق تم التوافق
عليها من جميع الاطراف ما يتم الان هو
صياغه مسوده الاتفاق بشكل نهائي على ضوء
ما تم التوافق عليه في اللقاءات المباشره
وغير المباشره بين جميع الاطراف وهذا امر
مهم
وهذا ما سنعود له بعد قليل سنعود الجانب
الانساني وكذلك الجانب الاقتصادي جوانب جد
مهمه في محاوله لترتيب الامور في داخل
اليمني تفضلوا بالبقاء معي ضيوفي الكرام
نعود بعد هذا الفاصل القصير مشاهدينا وفي
تناقش
الملف الانساني وخاصه المتعلق بالاسرى هل
ينجح في اعاده الثقه بين اطراف المجتمع
اليمني
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات